[Musique]
avec nous à québec joué live band
candidat dans louis hébert pour le parti
libéral du canada monsieur live band
bonsoir bonsoir monsieur fillon alors
vous avez le parti libéral votre
gouvernement a ajouté 70 milliards de
dollars en déficit dans votre premier
mandat
et là vous promettez encore presque 100
milliards là pour le prochain mandat
est ce que c'est bien responsable ça
d'abord il est important de rappeler
quelques éléments fondamentale quand
hervé au pouvoir en 2015 et cadettes en
récession technique on a fait un choix
qui était différent de celui des
conservateurs de monsieur harper des
consommateurs aujourd'hui de monsieur
chiffres c'est à dire que plutôt que de
faire une obsession avec l'austérité
avec les coupures on préfère investir
hors donner plus à ceux qui en ont le
plus besoin mais sans infrastructures en
sciences en recherche réduire les
inégalités et on voit que depuis quatre
ans cette approche a porté fruit d'une
part on a créer un million d'emplois
dans l'économie canadienne depuis quatre
ans on est un taux de chômage qui est
historiquement bas on voit que les
salaires sont à la hausse et que la
pauvreté a reculé au canada de 20% de
40% chez les enfants donc je pense est
dans cette lignée la con qu'on poursuit
mais il faut rappeler que le canada une
cote de crédit le triple a dont les
grains des deux seuls pays où dans le g7
qui dispose d'une telle cote de crédit
et donc d'ajouter 100 milliards de
déficit après 70 milliards quand vous
êtes arrivé au pouvoir le budget en
équilibre
est ce que vous venez pas mettre en
danger justement cette note triple a en
additionnant en augmentant les déficits
et sans donner de retour à l'équilibré
budgétaire on a l'impression que les
dépenses galope et que les déficits
s'additionnent maintenant parce que
quand on parle de mettre en péril la
cote de crédit du quart d'heure au
contraire la preuve qu'on prend c'est de
regarder à ce que la taille de
l'économie canadienne
alors qu'elle croît de regarder ce que
notre quote note aux ratios de dette par
rapport à la taille de l'économie est en
constante diminution
ce lait depuis le début de notre mandat
en 2015 ça va continuer de l'être au
cours des quatre prochaines années cette
valeur ces avantages pilote vous avez
réajuster avec le cadre financier sa
baie sera pas au départ que prévu parce
qu'on décide d'investir dans les gens de
redonner par exemple aux aînés
de 75 ans et plus en augmentant la
sécurité de la vieillesse et en
augmentant la prestation pour survivants
on sait que les plusieurs qui on a dit
qu'on amuse à la joindre les deux bouts
qui ont besoin d'un peu de un peu de
soutien puis on voit que dans les pays
par exemple scandinaves où les
inégalités ont tendance à être
décroissante on voit qu'une meilleure
répartition de la richesse
ça donne des économies robustes
résiliente et ça donne des résultats au
niveau de la croissance et c'est ce
qu'on a livré aussi au canada
si on se précipite juste si on s'envoie
récession en 2020 ou 2021
combien déficit 70 100 milliards mais je
pense que justement avec les
investissements qu'on fait depuis 2016
et alors que l'on propose aucun doute
continuer sur cette approche on met les
bases pour une économie qui est beaucoup
plus résiliente et la marge de manoeuvre
fiscale
elle est là on a la mer aussi on
fiscales des pays du g7
et comme je le mentionnais note ratio
dette pib est en constante diminution et
ça revient sur l'offre est difficile
c'est pas grave mais c'est je pense que
l'obsession de l'austérité quand vous
parliez du la position fiscale du canada
en 2015 et l' équilibre budgétaire
demain sur un peu et ça s'est fait sur
le dos de qui ça s'est fait sur le dos
de coupures en science ça s'est fait sur
le dos de coupures en culture en culture
coupures chez les vétérans ça s'est fait
avec des allègements fiscaux au mieux
nantis aussi notre approche elle est
complètement différente de celle des
conservateurs où on ne fait pas de
l'austérité des coupures notre notre
obsession
on décide d'investir de réduire les
inégalités ça porte fruit ça marche
alors la taxe de 3% sur les géants du
web ce sont des mots qu'on attend de
votre part depuis quatre ans la taxe
netflix
on a eu lui même tout un débat où vous
aviez l'occasion de l'annoncé cette taxe
netflix pourquoi vous avez attendu
lorsqu'on vient annoncer au delà de la
taxe netflix usa mais ce qui est encore
plus important c'est qu'on calcule
approche française on s'inspire de ce
qui s'est fait en france on vient
imposer les revenus publicité les géants
du web qui ont une présence à
l'international ce qui va nous générer
des revenus très intéressante une
approche par intérim en attendant de
voir la proche du mondial de l'eau cd
howe occidentale de l' ocde
mais pour moi c'est une excellente
nouvelle je pense que oui peut-être pour
certains ça a pris plus de temps à me
suis dit que je défends au sein du parti
et du gouvernement libéral
mais je pense que les canadiens
réaliser qu'ils entrent l'approchent
mettons de stephen harper qui était très
dogmatique qui étaient bloquées qui se
refusait d'écouter la nôtre est très
positive on est ouvert on est ouvert aux
bonnes idées on veut faire ça par
exemple de manière responsable
vous avez quatre ans parce qu'on en a
parlé en masse de taxes netflix puis
vous disiez non non non on ne fera pas
ça et quand on disait il faudrait que
netflix comme les autres perçoivent la
tps vous disiez non non non on ne veut
pas taxer davantage des canadiens
aujourd'hui vous êtes prêt à taxer
davantage de calais avec la tps d'un
point de vue d'équité mais aussi et puis
pour sa part c'est plus fondamental
encore d'imposer les revenus des gens du
web parce que la taxe quand on parle la
tps comme vous le mentionnez c'est vrai
que c'est les canadiens les
consommateurs qui la paient utilement
mais les revenus des gens du web c'est
ce qu'il faut à l'imposer c'est ce que
la france a décidé de faire par intérim
c'est ce que le canada vous faire vous
avez que je suis très haut débit dans ce
remake on met de l'avant que cette
approche vous avez complètement changé
de vie là dessus mais notre approche
serait ce qu on veut travailler avec les
partenaires à l'international mais on
décide de prendre une mesure par intérim
en attendant qu'il ya une mesure
concerter avec l'os et depuis on va
continuer d'avoir du leadership à l'
ocde sur cette question mais moi je
pense une excellente nouvelle
est ce qu'une possibilité en taxant
comme ça les géants américains du web
que vous vous retrouviez dans un ouvre
un nouvel affront avec l'administration
trump mais je pense qu'à la à la
différence de ce qu'on vous parlait de
10 à 90 à 3 ans il ya un plus grand
consensus international sur l'importance
de venir imposer à juste titre les gens
doivent lui même aux etats-unis une
discussion qu'ils ont en ce moment quand
je regarde la la primaire américaine
du côté démocrate donc je pense que pour
nous c'est c'est important avons une
approche irresponsable je pense pas que
c'est un risque
est ce que le directeur parlementaire du
budget a raison de parler d'
incertitudes élevées sur vos projections
parce qu'il est difficile d'estimer
l'assiette fiscale et parce que
statistique canada ne collecte pas les
informations sur les revenus du géant du
web pour nous on se base sur l'
expertise puis lettre du directeur
parlementaire du budget pour avec ses
chefs l'on pense qu'ils sont
raisonnables et responsables et toutes
nos mesures dans la plateforme
il vous dit je comprends qu'il ya de
l'incertitude par rapport aux revenus
exact qu'on valait généré mai selon les
données qu'on a et on entre avec le
directeur parlementaire du budget avec
ces chiffres là ça nous donne les
chiffres qui ont été dévoilées puis je
soumettrai
que le parti conservateur n'a pas encore
dévoilé une plateforme chiffrer toutes
majeures de notre plateforme ont été
faits en travaillant avec le directeur
parlementaire du budget est un
engagement qu'on avait d'un point de vue
de la transparence même qui avait une
paye de l'ancien directeur parlementaire
du budget salué le gouvernement disait
qu'on compte comme qu'on excel ou entre
copains une très bonne note au niveau de
la transparence de la responsabilité
fiscale aussi de la plateforme qui a été
proposé dernier point pourquoi bonifier
la sécurité de vieillesse à 75 et non
pas 65
je vois qu'au québec 23 % des gens
vivent avec moins de la moitié du revenu
médian mais 23% déjà 65 ans et plus mais
beaucoup de gens qui aimeraient une
bonification bien avant l'âge de 75 ans
déjà quand on regarde ce qu'on a fait au
niveau des aînés on a ramené l'âge de la
retraite à 65 ans on à bonifier le
supplément de revenu garanti c'est une
première chose qu'on a fait de 10 % en
2016 ça a eu un grand impact pour les
aînés les plus vulnérables et là on a
aussi dans le dernier budget vous le
savez monsieur fillion augmenter le la
limite ou un ennemi à faible revenu peut
travailler et garder l'argent dans ses
poches en augmentant exemption pour le
supplément de revenu garanti jusqu'à
15000 dollars
le plat 75 ans en augmentant de 10 % la
sécurité de la vieillesse je pense que
c'est de reconnaître que les coûts de la
vie augmente que les revenus ne suivent
pas nécessairement bien monsieur layton
merci beaucoup pour cet entretien ce
soir ça me fait très plaisir bonne
soirée au revoir